when what was the last time
you had a job like when was that time
where you finally quit quit your job
what was that job like
that you actually were getting a
paycheck for
when
when i came home and
i came home in 2013. this was nine years
ago
i came home in 2013. i was
i just had
came back and i had one went on a
violation
so i went to like a violation program
willard and i came back
um i was only gone for five months but
after you you come home from
from a bed and then you come home for a
couple months and then you go back on
fire then you come back it's like yeah
[ __ ] your ass down right so i was in a
when i'm sitting down so i was really
falling back i was like going around the
hood and uh
i'm a [ __ ] like i signed up for
school
uh i met a good great nice wholesome
girl
and i'm saying she was my girlfriend at
the time she
she like
i was going to church with her
wow
and then like i went to uh i remember
she got her brother a job
like
like cleaning like the executive suites
at the bill stadium
and she pulled up to this [ __ ] and her
brother ain't coming so she was like
damn like he was panicking like man her
brother ain't coming i mean and i liked
her so much i'm like i tell him i do it
you know you see that
and i worked it and i was cleaning so
you actually was at the bill's stadium
to talk about
that's really what happened what i'm
saying that's what happened and now
you're in that [ __ ] in the suite
eating the food that's the fact on the
field that's a fact performing doing the
anthem how crazy is that it's [ __ ]
beautiful man that [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
that's crazy bro well listen bro i
appreciate you pulling up tana talk four
incredible incredible body of work man
appreciate you love coming up here
having these talks with you you know how
we kick off course of course psf almond
in april
tana talk four in march ah you know what
i'm saying let's [ __ ] go to butcher
coming let's go boom